murder trial of derek shovin in
minneapolis the defense
lawyer and the prosecutors told as you
might expect very different stories in
court before the testimony began
yesterday and then witnesses
revealed some things we did not know
about the death of george floyd let's go
now to jamie yukis who is outside the
courthouse where the trial resumes again
this morning day two
jamie good morning to you good morning
tony during jury selection some of the
jurors said they'd seen only part of the
video
one even said they hadn't seen it at all
as the video played
one juror grabbed her chair and another
had her hand on her temple
the video is a powerful tool for the
prosecution and there are studies that
show
almost 80 percent of jurors make up
their mind during opening statements
the defense though made its own case in
its opening statement saying the video
is not the whole story again though we
want to warn you
the video is very disturbing when they
replayed the video
of george on the ground i had to walk
out even to this day i still haven't
watched the video in full
george floyd's nephew brandon williams
watched the trial with his family from a
separate room
as the prosecution played all nine
minutes of the video that started a
worldwide movement
against police brutality you can believe
your eyes
that it's a homicide smurf prosecutor
jerry blackwell told the jury that the
video of derrick chovin
is definitive evidence of excessive
force he
put his knees upon his neck and his back
grinding and crushing him until
the very breath no ladies and gentlemen
until the very life
were squeezed out of him but defense
attorney eric nelson argued that chauvin
was simply following training
the use of force is not attractive
but it is a necessary component of
policing
and that floyd's death was not caused by
chauvin's actions
but rather drugs and other factors mr
floyd
died of a cardiac arrhythmia that
occurred as a result of hypertension
his coronary disease the ingestion of
methamphetamine and fentanyl
and the adrenaline prosecutors also
revealed never before seen surveillance
footage from across the street
911 dispatcher jenna scurry the first
witness was watching it all
unfold through that camera when
prosecutors say she called the police
on the police you can call me a snitch
if you want to but we have the cameras
up for
320's call and all of them sat on this
man
she said she thought the screen was
frozen because there was no movement for
so long
my instincts were telling me that
something's wrong something
is not right i don't know what but
something wasn't right
donald williams prosecutor's third
witness was on the scene that day
he's not even resisting arrest right now
bro
williams a previous security officer
with mixed martial arts experience
described what he saw you see his
foot is under his toe is pointing down
and you will see a small adjuster in his
back foot
and that's just the pressure you push
more down between
his knee george's head and the concrete
ben crump is the floyd family attorney
i thought that the prosecution presented
well today
i thought the first witness was a
bombshell brandon williams says the
family
is leaning on each other are you going
to be able to take in
all the information week after week we
came here
just to get justice whatever it takes
and
we won't stop until we get it
while we don't know who's on the witness
list for later this morning we do know
donald williams the man who describes
chauvin's choke
will be first to finish his testimony
before being cross-examined
at some point prosecutors will call the
chief of police to testify
that the knee on the neck is not a
normal police maneuver
this testimony will be highly unusual
because he's testifying against one of
his own
former officers gail boy jamie thank you
very much